[Musique]
ici et si je vous disais que nous avons
l'opportunité de rompre le cycle de
violence de notre société
et si nous pouvons apprendre de ceux qui
sont au coeur de cette violence ceux qui
ont vécu ce cycle et si c'était en
prison que se trouvait la solution
aujourd'hui je vous amène avec moi en
prison c'est parti je vous invite pour
commencer à fermer les yeux
nous passons d'abord le contrôle de
sécurité et d'identité
nous traversons ensuite une et puis deux
puis trois grilles automatique qui
claquent dans un bruit de métal
stridents tout est gris et morne
nous entrons dans une grande salle et là
il y à des hommes
nous sommes en cercle avec des
prisonniers
les résidents de la prison ils sont tous
habillés de bleu et vous remarqué comme
moi qui ne se parlent contre personne de
même couleur de peau vous pouvez
maintenant réouvrir les yeux c'est une
histoire unique que je vais vous
raconter celle qui m'amène depuis trois
ans aller en prison tous les jours mais
être bénévole en prison c'était pas sur
ma to do list
mon parcours c'est bien autre chose
déménagement aux états unis dans la napa
valley
quand j'avais 6 ans
implication totale pendant toute ma
jeunesse dans la création de notre
propriété viticole familiale d'une
grande école d'ingénieur un un billet à
berck les 20 ans de vie professionnelle
vécu en entreprise une vie sur quatre
continents à développer des produits
innovants comme pour le cancer et
l'accès lectrices ite et tout cela à des
postes à responsabilité c'est pas tout à
fait ce qui conduit à la prison est
pourtant un jour de l'été 2015
j'ai entendu une petite voix me dire 20
prison alors c'est venu de nulle part
bien sûr j'ai rejeté et en même temps le
plus je repoussais cette idée absurde le
plus je me sentais happé par elle
je ne pouvais plus l'ignorer et n'ayant
aucune idée de comment me retrouver en
prison mais j'ai tapé sur google prison
à san diego et sept mois plus tard le 5
décembre 2015
les grilles de la prison de dans nos
veines deux des 33 prisons d'état de la
californie s'ouvre et dès mes premiers
échanges avec les résidents je me sens
tranquille à l'aise comme chez moi et là
mon petit saboteur intérieur se déchaîne
il s'acharne à me démontrer que je suis
tombé sur la tête
il questionne tout comme une
mitraillette mais qu'est ce qui te
prends qu'est ce que quelqu'un comme toi
qu'un pack puissant va faire en prison
battus sérieusement pas c'était journée
à aider des tueurs des braqueurs et des
violeurs et surtout les victimes dans
tout ça tu pense à elle
et pourtant il existe au plus profond de
moi ce feu brûlant qui paisiblement et
touba me dit vas-y foncé
tu as un rôle à y jouer tu le découvrira
au fur et à mesure que tu avances et
donc j'avance en mettant un pied devant
l'autre
je vais à la prison de dans nos veines
trois fois par semaine
j'ai créé anime plusieurs programmes
j'ai même l'idée d'y organiser des tedx
vous rendez compte
tous les ans cent personnes achètent des
billets comme vous pour passer la
journée en prison elle vivre une journée
d'intervention et des changes
alex en hommes en bleu le tout organisé
par une équipe de quinze résidents et
réalisé avec l'aide de 70 résidents
bénévoles supplémentaires et au fur et à
mesure de mes visites à dans nos veines
je réalise que derrière quasiment tout
acte violent
il existe une histoire unique d'humains
pris dans la violence je comprends petit
à petit que chaque histoire de vie pour
avoir une toute nouvelle fin je commence
à entrevoir l'idée folle que pour rompre
le cycle de violence de notre société
ces résidents sont les mieux placés
regardons d'abord comment fonctionne ce
cycle sociétale de la violence il est
sans fin les personnes embourbé dedans
ont donc beaucoup de mal à s'en extraire
même quand elles en ont le désir prenons
deux jeunes par exemple john est l'aîné
de sept enfants
son quotidien n'est que violence abus
sexuels de son père haine et mépris de
sa mère droguée un flingue passé sur la
tempe par un voisin sans amour familial
john atteindre un gang et pour être
reconnu dans ce gang il commet des actes
violents à l'âge de 19 ans john est
condamné à la prison à vie
on lui dit qu'il était irrécupérable et
va mourir en prison en prison
la violence continue alcool drogues gang
violent poignard d'âge
aujourd'hui john a 42 ans et son fils a
déjà fait plusieurs tours en centre de
détention pour mineurs avec l'histoire
de john et bien d'autres j'ai compris
que les personnes blessées blesse les
personnes violentes et violentes comme
le disent les hommes en bleu la violence
à répétition créer une déconnexion avec
l'humanité et ensuite c'est simple de
s'en prendre à elle c'était donc ça il
était déconnecté l'humanité et donc ils
devaient se reconnecter mais comment
faire pour qu'il retrouve en eux mêmes
une raison d'être
d'abord à doha nos veines nous
travaillons qu'avec des résidents motivé
pour sortir de leur parcours destructeur
ce travail ne fonctionne que s'ils font
eux mêmes ce choix car ils nécessitent
volonté vulnérabilité et courage et puis
ensuite on applique la recette de la
mayonnaise
vous la connaissez la recette on prend
des oeufs de la moutarde et de l'huile
que l'on monte dans un bol sans
s'arrêter jusqu'à cela devienne une
émulsion délicieuse alors chaque fois
qu'on se retrouve en cercle avec les
hommes en bleu on applique cinq
ingrédients 1 une écoute sans attente et
son jugement
2 un espace de travail sécurisé en tenue
par un cadre intransigeant 3 une
responsabilisation total 40 places et
résidant au coeur de quasi toutes
décisions
4 un déblocage de leur créativité
existantes et 5 une mise en relation
avec l'autre pour et découvertes amical
et de là découle dialogue ensuite
relation compréhension et enfin
connexion et comme pour la mayonnaise
ont mélangé cinq ingrédients avec une
présence permanente sans s'arrêter
ce travail prend du temps est
intensément personnel donc vous garder
le rythme et puis la magie
transformationnel prend cette magie
s'est dans un premier temps la
transformation de la personne samuel en
est un bel exemple
tout jeune samuel décrète vouloir et
criminel ce choix de vie l'amène une
première fois en prison il participe à
des programmes de réhabilitation et
l'abandonnent ces comportements
criminels
il sort de prison mais 50 jours plus
tard il est de retour en prison cette
fois avec une peine à vie
là je sélectionne samuel avec neuf
autres résidents pour faire partie de la
première équipe organisatrice du tedx on
applique notre set de la mayonnaise et
au fur et à mesure de la préparation du
tedx j'ai vu samuel avant la
vulnérabilité et le courage de regarder
en face sa propre violence
il l'a traversée il a utilisé pour en
faire sa mayonnaise
lors de sa première incarcération samuel
a su se conformer au cadre disciplinaire
et lors de sa deuxième il a su se
reconnecter à lui-même et à l'humanité
de tueurs dans un gang
samuel est devenu bienveillant et
positif ces moments les plus sombres de
son d'une source de lumière et
aujourd'hui les résidents le considère
qu'en majeur de grand frère modèles et
les gardiens le reconnaissent comme
quelqu'un droit comme un i un jour
curieuse de comprendre la différence
entre ces deux séjours en prison lui
pose la question comment as-tu aussi
rapidement perdu les comportements
positifs que tu avais acquis lors de sa
première incarcération
sa réponse est directe
c'est simple je savais pas encore qui
jetait cette transformation individuelle
est déjà une grande victoire et elle
n'est qu'un début
c'est ce qui en découle qui m'a
émerveillé et c'est là que j'ai
découvert une solution unique pour
rompre le cycle sociétale de la violence
voici scott sorti de prison après quinze
années est déterminé à créer son rêve
un dojo de taekwondo pour enseigner aux
jeunes à risque
les leçons que lui n'avait pas reçu
enfants
après sa sortie de prison un
concessionnaire auto lui propose un
boulot de vendeur et à la fin du premier
mois il est nommé vendeur du mois le
deuxième mois vendeur du mois le
troisième mois vendeur du mois et ça
continue jusqu'au neuvième mois quand un
investisseur touché par sa vision et sa
détermination offre de soutenir scott
avec les 25000 dollars nécessaires pour
lancer son dojo aujourd'hui scott
travaille avec 60 jeunes à risque
quotidiennement leurs enseignants les
règles du taekwondo ainsi que les règles
du vertueux et samuel et scott ne sont
pas des cas isolés
voilà les amis où se trouve la vraie
magie c'est cette contagion positive que
j'aime nommé l'effet papillon lors de
nos programmes
les résidents découvre pourquoi et
comment ils ont été pris par le cycle de
la violence
nombreux sont ceux que j'ai vus
s'illumine et des hommes qui ont vécu
vingt trente quarante ans de violence
découvrent leur beauté intérieure et la
pam la lumière jaillit septfonds soeurs
partagent alors ce cadeau avec leurs
enfants et leur famille d'abord et puis
avec le jazz autres résidents cet effet
papillon gagnent même les gardiens et ça
va encore plus loin
ces résidences offre alors une nouvelle
voie aux jeunes à risque
ils sont motivés car ils ont vécu la
même enfance
ils savent leur parler et deviennent
leur meilleur mentor ils comprennent la
dynamique de la violence telle que moi
je pourrai jamais la comprendre et une
fois lancé un possible de les arrêter
ils ont des idées positives pour tous et
leurs idées vont toujours pour loin ça
semble tellement absurde
et c'est la vérité que je vis au
quotidien hélas pour moi ça devient
clair ceux qui sont à la source du
problème de la violence sont aussi au
coeur de la solution
et oui lors qu'elles se reconnecte à
l'humanité les personnes que la société
avait écarté comme inhumaines devienne
une solution pour rompre le cycle
sociétale de la violence aujourd'hui mon
petit saboteur se réveille encore
parfois mais les réponses je les ai en
octobre 2017
j'ai mis de côté mes ambitions
professionnelles pour fonder une session
une association à but non lucratif
appelé brillance inside ce qui sera due
à peu près comme brillance à l'intérieur
qui offre à dans nos veines cinq
programmes ainsi qu'un programme de
réinsertion à l'extérieur car ces hommes
en bleu et moins enseigné à moi trois
principes
premièrement ils peuvent s'ils le
souhaitent
rédiger une toute nouvelle fin à leur
histoire de vie de chacun d'eux possède
une brillance unique au fond 2 et 3 ils
peuvent devenir une solution performante
pour basque pour créer basculer vers un
cycle vertueux réduisant la violence et
le nombre de victimes est oui d'ailleurs
même les pdg et dirigeants d'entreprises
s'intéressent à la création de ses
équipes performantes
ils viennent à la prison rencontrer les
résidents vivent ce travail et sont
épatés ils parlent eux aussi de leur
propre métamorphose ainsi que d'un effet
papillon a appliquées à leurs
entreprises
un jour un résident me dis et mariette
ces ingrédients dont on parle tout le
temps
bah il fonctionne aussi au boulot dans
nos relations nos entourages des
conflits tout quoi et oui dans nos
boulots à la maison et dans nos
relations
c'est aussi possible de passer d'un
cycle de violences un cycle de paix vous
rappelez-vous des ingrédients pour faire
une bonne mayonnaise et bien écoutez
vous offrez vous un cadre solide pour
libérer votre esprit
voyez-vous responsable de vos choix et
leurs conséquences ont créé activement
votre nouvelle réalité
connectez vous à vous même et finalement
accepté que ceci est un travail continu
revenons au cercle avec les amants bleus
vous avez de nouveau à fermer vos yeux
que voyez vous des hommes d'origines
différentes partagent et échangent
toutes communautés confondues
vous voyez le courage qu'ils expriment
tous les jours pour rester fidèles à
leur essence retrouver vous ressentez la
dignité le respect et l'amour en eux
vous voyez qu'ils peuvent effectivement
être au coeur de la solution
certains ont été jugés des monstres
aujourd'hui vous voyez des hommes voici
à quoi ressemble le pouvoir de cette
liberté intérieure retrouver alors
maintenant réouvre et vos yeux
je vous remercie
[Musique]